welcome to the show everybody thanks for
watching so
let me just say for to start with here
that I
I am very sympathetic to parents because
I am a parent I've got three kids I know
how difficult it is to be a parent or I
should say we back up for a minute
because parents always like to say well
being a parent is the hardest job in the
world I've said it myself that's true
with a qualifier
to raise a child to be a good person in
this degenerate disgusting culture that
is the hardest job in the world for sure
that is a 24/7 never sleep
round-the-clock relentless stressful
heartbreaking strenuous job that it just
just never never ends and it involved
every fiber of your being must be
invested in it all the time constantly
if you want to raise your kid to be a
good person in that so that's the
hardest job in the world but just to
raise a kid in general if by raising a
kid we mean well that you have them in
your house and you feed them food and
you put the TV on for them and you make
sure they're wearing some kind of
clothing and maybe you take them on a
vacation every once a while if that's
what we mean by raising a kid well then
no that's not the hardest job in the
world that that in and of itself is not
a difficult job at all actually
literally anyone can do it and anyone
does do it so that in and of itself is
not hard what is hard is raising your
kid to be a good person I fear that the
problem is that many parents in this
culture aren't so much worried about the
moral formation of their kids they're
not worried about raising their kids to
be good people they're more worried
about well they need to be a good
student they need to get good grades
like we got to get them into a good
college we got to make sure they get a
good career they're our parents weren't
worried about any of this stuff
whatsoever but there are plenty of
parents who are worried about that but
it's tight in terms of the the state of
their child's soul well they don't
concern themselves as much with that and
that is just
parents such as bad parenting that is
awful parenting that is non parenting
that is you may as well not even be
parenting that is pet you could you
could just make a robot with a computer
algorithm that could do that the hard
part is the moral formation and I fear
that a lot of us just don't worry about
that I bring that up just as a means of
introduction to this topic which i think
is kind of an illustration of a larger
problem so every um every year it seems
like we get maybe I don't know 10 or 12
national dress code outrages it's always
the same thing
a teenager goes to school dressed
inappropriately or hardly dressed at all
and the school is forced to reassert its
dress code policies and that of course
is person that's it that's a horrible
oppressive thing and it persecutes the
poor child and she runs home she runs
home to her mother and tells her mother
and the mother calls the school and
alerts the media and then the child who
by the way is so embarrassed by all this
and humiliated then goes on social media
and tells everyone in the world because
that's what you do when you're
embarrassed about something you tell
everybody and then that's how it becomes
a national outrage this happens like I
said probably ten or twelve times a year
and it's it's it really ramps up when we
get into the warmer weather so we're
starting to see now and we got our first
dose of this this week with a national
dress code outrage I think it's our
first of the year one of many I'm sure
before the years up I gotta go I'm not
gonna go into the specifics of this
story it doesn't really matter I'm just
using this as an intro as a means into
this larger conversation I mean in this
case it was the girl she went to school
without undergarments on and that was a
problem for the school understandably
they handled it they handled the problem
in kind of a clumsy weird way and so
then the daughter went home and told the
mom and the mom and the daughter are now
saying that she's persecuted and it's
terrible and she's been sexualized and
so on and so forth now it is true that
schools are very often clumsy and as I
said and awkward and weird and how they
deal with this stuff
but I don't fault them for that because
they shouldn't have to deal with it at
all
and there really isn't any non awkward
way for an adult to tell another adults
kid that she's not wearing enough
clothing there is no way to do that no
way at all that will not be embarrassing
to everybody involved in the situation
there's just once you have as an adult
as a parent put another adult in the
position where they have to have that
conversation you have put them in a
lose-lose situation there's nothing they
can do so the schools as they're you
know looking at the this issue they have
two general avenues they can take the
first Avenue is let's do nothing and
just accept the fact that all that our
hallways are going to resemble a
downtown bar at 1:00 a.m. on a Saturday
we'll just accept that and whatever or
we can try to impose some basic standard
of decency and decorum and dignity in
our school I respect the schools that
take the latter approach I give them a
lot of leeway even when they do it
awkwardly I can generally be pretty hard
on the school system I admit but but I
acknowledge that they are in an
unenviable situation in an almost
impossible situation where they are
constantly having to do things
that parents won't do
and they're constantly having to have
these conversations that parents won't
have with their kids
sometimes the sometimes the schools go
too far they take too much Liberty and
so for instance they'll you know they
want to talk to the kids about sex like
in kindergarten now because they say
well the parents aren't doing it that's
something that you got to leave to the
parents and if they don't do it they
don't do it but that's not for the
schools to do at all except for teaching
the kids the basic biological scientific
facts of sex when it wouldn't when it's
appropriate for their age group in
science but beyond that to go any more
into sexual ethics or telling them when
to have sex and you know just that's not
for the schools to do especially
government schools but
basic decency basic modesty well if they
don't have a conversation about that
with the kids and the parents don't have
a conversation with that about that with
the kids then we're back to the schools
looking like a red-light district and
that's not really an acceptable outcome
so the schools have to do something now
we were discussing this a couple days
ago in my um Facebook group and I
received quite a few messages from
teachers who tell me that kids regularly
come to school these are their words not
mine
dressed like hookers and streetwalkers
and there's nothing they can do about it
and one thing that all these teachers
echoed to me is that those of us who are
not in school and those of us who don't
have teenagers we probably don't really
understand how bad it is how crazy it's
gotten with the outfits and just the
inappropriate ridiculous as they say
hookerish outfits that these kids are
coming schooling now maybe it's not like
this in every school but some of these
stories that teachers told me I mean
it's
you know I graduated high school I don't
know how old am I now I graduated high
school like 15 years ago around there 15
20 years ago 25 I don't know but for me
it wasn't so long ago that things should
have changed that much but and it was
pretty bad when I went to school but
it's apparently so much worse even
though but if the parents are loaded to
the problem and this is the case you
know not just with dress code stuff but
just in general if you listen to the
teachers this is what they say you try
to talk to a parent about a problem
involving the kid and the parents will
rush to their little darlings defense
and become very indignant that anyone
would dare give their poor child a
lecture how dare you it's none of your
business to which the school should
reply well when you send your kid into
public half naked it is our business now
you've made it our business I wish it
wasn't but now it is that's your fault
be a parent
but of course the real source of their
indignation is embarrassment they are
not embarrassed over the conduct of
their child like they should be they're
embarrassed
and they feel personally chastised that
a school employee had to mop up after
they're negligent parenting they realize
on some level that they're doing a
terrible job parenting they're not
really parenting at all and so the
schools had to do it for him and that
makes them feel bad and that's why you
know the parents who not like I said not
just with wardrobes but when a kid is
being disruptive acting out and the
schools have to talk to a parent about
when the parent gets defensive and so
there's no way how that my kid didn't do
that you this is the teacher doesn't
like if it's all your fault is being
persecuted not not all parents respond
that way that's not how my parents
responded when I went to school and I
got in trouble but the parents who do
respond that way it's they're not
defending their kid they're defending
themselves that's all they're doing it's
just selfishness it's all about them
they're defending themselves and they're
saying how dare you because if it's true
that my kids doing that then that means
that maybe I'm doing something wrong at
home and I can't face that fact so No
but this is what you get parents when
you leave the parenting to the school
system it's embarrassing for you
and I imagine it must be embarrassing
when you've got to come in and have a
meeting with a teacher talk to a teacher
on the phone and hear all these things
that your kids doing wrong
Barisan but if your kid you know if your
kid gets a lectured by the assistant
principal over her miniskirt or whatever
don't be indignant at the school
the assistant principal was just doing
something that you refused to do it
should have been you giving the lecture
but you didn't do it so they had to do
it would have been better coming from
you but you didn't do it so they did
that's your fault be indignant at
yourself be embarrassed about yourself
be angry at yourself
if you're not going to do your job then
the school system is going to pinch-hit
and the school system has to do a lot of
pinch-hitting because there are a lot of
parents who just aren't doing their job
and I think the school system oftentimes
does a bad job of pinch-hitting but it's
an indictment on America's parents that
they even have to step up to the plate
at all because they shouldn't have to
here is a here's an idea
maybe we should instill in our children
a sense of dignity and self-respect
maybe we should teach their modesty and
we should teach them to be humble we
should teach them to address with class
and with maturity maybe we should teach
them to stop seeking attention maybe we
should teach them to respect authority
teach them to be adults in a civilized
society the whole this is the whole
point of parenting if you're not going
to see to your child's moral formation
then what are you doing
what what exactly are you doing
and your parents say well I mean I don't
want to force my child to be a certain
way I don't want to force him to fit
into a box I want him to find himself he
doesn't know how to find himself he
doesn't know where to look he's confused
he's a kid he doesn't know who he is
he's a he's a he's a child he doesn't
know anything he knows nothing about
about anything that's your job to tell
him to show him to guide him don't say
how long he's got to find themselves
he's got to figure out his identity he's
got to express himself he doesn't know
any he's confused don't you see that
he's bewildered he's got he doesn't know
which way is up because you never told
him that's your job
so yes you should be you should be
getting your child to conform with with
uh with you should be conforming with
basic standards of etiquette and decency
and courtesy
he should be conforming with some kind
of moral structure
he should be conforming with the rules
of the family he should be conforming
with the rules in the school he should
be conforming under the authority of
those who are above him he should be
conforming with the idea that he should
respect his elders yes he should be
conforming to all of those things those
are boxes that he should be fitting in
and you should be putting him in those
boxes that's your job again
if you're not gonna do that as a parent
then and I say this with all due respect
but as a parent you're basically useless
you're not doing anything that there are
specific things that society needs
parents to do and in this case if you're
one of those you're not doing any of
those things so what what's the point
what are you doing you may as well just
ship them to a boarding school or
something at that point because you're
not the whole the whole parenting deal
you've just checked out on know what
he's gonna find himself I mean people
say this now about their you know people
say this now about like their four year
olds oh he's got to find themselves
gonna kind of figure out his own
identity he's for you
nutcase what are you doing he's four
years old gotta find himself
can't find out he can't even tie his
shoes doesn't know anything yeah you got
to tell him he's a boy this is what boys
do this is how boys act
again that's your job you're a parent
[Music]
all right got a little worked up there I
I just it really this is the thing this
is the thing above maybe anything else
in the society that irritates me the
most
these parents who just categorically
refused to do their job refused to do it
one other point
one other point I want to make okay and
I know this is a thing that gets me into
trouble but
when we're talking you know just going
back specifically to the dress-code
issue one of the things that you hear
sometimes is that
one of the reasons why we should have
dress codes and why we should teach our
daughters to respect the dress codes is
that it can be very distracting for boys
in school if the girls are coming in
dressed like they're going to the beach
right
and we when someone makes that argument
we tend to write that off and say that's
a but that's a silly sexist patriarchal
argument it's not my problem what your
boy does I had some I yeah if your boy
can't control himself is not my problem
it's not my daughter's problem he's got
to deal with it
that's a terrible attitude
it's a terrible attitude to instill in
your daughter is a terrible obnoxious
selfish ugly attitude it is not sexist
to point out that your daughter's skimpy
outfits really are extremely distracting
to the boys in her school
they are
if you've never been a teenage boy and
you've never been the parent of a
teenage boy then you really do not
understand the overwhelming power that a
boy's hormones have over him at a
certain age and I know that girls have
four months to and they've got their own
issues with that not downplaying that at
all but those are different issues and
it's not the same and the the fixation
on the opposite sex
on sex in general this is something that
is so much more pronounced for boys than
it is for girls that's just a biological
reality there are exceptions but they
are just that exception for the most
part it is so much more powerful and
pronounced in boys and they can't
control that they can't you know we
could try to teach them to control their
actions but they can't control the
fixation they can't control what their
mind is doing inside their head it's not
an exaggeration to say that it is very
nearly impossible very nearly impossible
for a for a pubescent boy to focus on
his work while his girl classmates are
coming to school barely clothed it's
it's you are asking him to do something
that is
practically impossible for him to do it
would require just I'll tell you this
when we put it this way it would require
more self-discipline and maturity and
moral courage then you probably have
right now as an adult
so you're asking him to exhibit a kind
of
control over his mind and his faculties
that you yourself do not exhibit so this
is just a fact of biology
maybe you as a parent should teach your
daughter
at her attempts to get attention are
harmful
not only to herself but also to her male
classmates who have almost no choice but
to give her the attention she's
demanding
it's it's look like a biological
imperative that they're gonna give that
attention and so she shouldn't be out
there seeking it it's selfish I mean it
is obviously selfish in more ways than
one
just a man I want really I mean I don't
think we empathize enough with boys in
this culture imagine what this culture
is like for boys and like I said I
remember how it was for me when I was a
kid not all that long ago and it was
very difficult but it's even it's it's
it's got to be ten times worse
even now than it was for me you're a boy
in 2018 there's porn everywhere there's
sex all over the TV there's sex all over
the computer and then he goes to school
and the girls are dressed like they're
going to the club and he just can't
escape every way he's got his hormones
raging he's going through puberty he's a
and everywhere he turns it can't turn
anywhere where it's not there I mean
it's it's it's you have any idea how
difficult we've made it for a boy to be
virtuous and chaste let let alone
productive
in this society
and so the the response of a lot of
parents of girls is that it's their
problem whatever
I mean how disgusting of an attitude is
that why don't you have a little bit I
mean look just stop thinking about
yourself for a second and just just for
a moment if you can and try to empathize
with these boys they didn't choose to be
this way this and they need you to live
in this culture either that is
constantly preying upon their weakest
impulses at a point in their life when
they have not developed the maturity and
the discipline to to overcome those
impulses
as I said as you know as adults we don't
were not prepubescent boys anymore so we
don't have the same impulses we don't
deal with the same struggles that they
do internally but what I'm saying is the
amount of self-discipline that we are
requiring boys to have
in in this culture
it is a greater self-discipline than
even most adults exhibit
that's not fair
yeah it's just not fair
so I don't know I mean that's not the
only reason why we should have the dress
codes but that is a reason I don't think
it's an irrelevant reason I think it's
something that we should all be
concerned about and maybe I mean we
focus so much on the plight of girls in
society and what they go through and the
societal expectations and everything and
that's great to focus on that because
that's an important issue I have a
daughter as well so I'm worried about
that but we just neglect all together we
just we just Scott what what boys go
through we just scoff at it we don't
care we're like just let them deal with
it it's their problem like I said it's
just that it's a disgusting attitude it
really is but that's maybe a topic for
another day I mean I will talk about
more about that some other time but
we'll leave it there for now so thanks
for watching everybody and have a great
day